I remember filming with David Hasselhoff
for wild boys we're trying to shoot one
thing and he's like dude we could have
shot three episodes of Baywatch by now
come on man
what I remember him like catching
himself in a mirror and be like God man
I look like dude I'm old but at
least I'm
rich the radest thing to say castle off
was always super cool to me dude the
best I really enjoyed I really enjoyed
being around him every once in a while
every few years I'll get a phone call
from him and he'll tell me what he's
been doing for 30 minutes and then say
bye and won't talk to him for a few
years you know but he was always super
super cool to me coest dud ever